there are several ways we can  incentivize colleges to reduce their  prices and encourage students to take  educational paths that maximize a return  on their investment for starters we need  to reduce the size of the federal  student loan program over time so that  schools can no longer take for granted  that applicants will be able to pay for  tuition no matter what the best way to  forgive student loan debt is through  personal bankruptcy student loans are  currently the only kind of debt that  cannot be discharged this way bankruptcy  is a system that ensures that only those  in dire straits get deaf forgiveness  while at the same time forcing them to  bear a penalty because it makes future  creditors wary of loaning to them simply  forgiving federal student debt on the  other hand means forcing us to bail out  other people for their bad decisions  while rewarding the very institutions  that have been ripping us off in the  first place  [Music]